ในบทนี้เราจะสำรวจ
ว่าคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมและคลาสสิก
ทำงานร่วมกันเพื่อแก้ปัญหาสำคัญที่สุดอย่างหนึ่ง
ในวิทยาศาสตร์ นั่นคือการประมาณพลังงานของโมเลกุลและวัสดุได้อย่างแม่นยำ
เราทำสิ่งนี้ได้โดย
ใช้ quantum circuit
ในการสร้างตัวอย่างสำหรับ qubit
ซึ่งจะถูกนำมาประมวลผลต่อ
และ diagonalize ด้วย algorithm ในกลุ่มนี้
ใน algorithm กลุ่มนี้
อย่างเช่น SQD และ SKG และยังมีคอร์สเต็มๆ บน
IBM Quantum Platform ที่อุทิศ
ให้กับพวกมันและวิธีการที่เกี่ยวข้อง
สำหรับจุดประสงค์ในส่วนนี้
เราจะอธิบายสั้นๆ
ไม่ว่าจะใช้ SQD หรือ SKG
เป้าหมายคือการหา eigenvector
และ eigenvalue ของ Hamiltonian matrix
matrix นี้อาจอธิบายพลังงานของระบบทางฟิสิกส์
หรือเคมี แต่ framework เดียวกัน
ก็ใช้แก้ปัญหาประเภทอื่นได้อีกมาก
เช่น โลจิสติกส์ บางครั้ง
matrix พวกนี้มีขนาดใหญ่มาก
ดังนั้นการลดขนาด
ของ matrix ขณะที่ยังคงคุณสมบัติสำคัญ
ของ ground state ไว้
อาจมีค่ามากทีเดียว นั่นคือเป้าหมายของ SQD
เราใช้คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมสร้าง subspace ที่มีประโยชน์
ที่ครอบคลุม ground state
จากนั้นเรา project Hamiltonian matrix ของเรา
ลงบน subspace นั้น ซึ่งทำให้ได้
matrix ขนาดเล็กลง ซึ่งจะ
วิเคราะห์ได้ง่ายกว่ามาก
โดยใช้การประมวลผลคลาสสิกแบบ high performance เราทำสิ่งนี้
ด้วยการเตรียม quantum state ทดลอง
ที่มักเรียกว่า ansatz
และทำการวัดเพื่อสุ่มตัวอย่างจาก ansatz นั้น
ใน computational basis ซึ่งให้เรา
ตัวอย่าง subspace ใน computational basis
แต่สิ่งที่เราอยากได้จริงๆ คือ
ground state ที่แท้จริง แล้วถ้า
subspace ที่สุ่มมาไม่ได้มี
องค์ประกอบที่จำเป็นทั้งหมดล่ะ
ถ้าเราเลือก ansatz ที่ดีกว่า
เราอาจประมาณ ground state ได้ดีขึ้น
นั่นนำเราไปสู่วิธีที่อิงการสุ่มตัวอย่าง
ที่เรียกว่า Sample-based Krylov Quantum Diagonalization หรือ SKQD ใน SKQD
เราเริ่มต้นด้วย ansatz
เหมือนเดิม แต่จะ apply quantum gate ที่ประมาณ
วิวัฒนาการตามเวลาของระบบทางฟิสิกส์
สามารถแสดงให้เห็นว่าด้วยข้อสมมติบางอย่าง
สิ่งนี้นำไปสู่การรับประกันว่า time-evolved
ansatz ทับซ้อนกับ ground state จริง
ทั้งสอง algorithm เริ่มต้นด้วย Hamiltonian matrix
ขนาดใหญ่มาก ทั้งคู่ทำงานต่างกันบ้าง
แต่ในทั้งสองกรณี ส่วนควอนตัมของ algorithm จะให้
subspace ที่ช่วยให้เราลดขนาด matrix ได้
ซึ่งเราหวังว่าจะยังคงคุณสมบัติสำคัญของ ground state
แล้ว high performance classical computing เข้ามามีบทบาทตรงไหน
สำหรับ Hamiltonian ขนาดใหญ่ที่สุด
และสำหรับการประมาณ ground state ที่แม่นยำที่สุด
แม้แต่ matrix ที่ถูก project แล้วก็ยังอาจมีขนาดใหญ่พอสมควร
ดังนั้นการใช้ประโยชน์จากคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิกที่ทรงพลังกว่า
จะช่วยให้เรา
ได้ผลลัพธ์ที่ดีขึ้น
และยังช่วยให้รับมือกับปัญหาขนาดใหญ่ขึ้นได้
เพื่อรวมทุกอย่างเข้าด้วยกัน
เราสามารถแทน algorithm ที่อิงการสุ่มตัวอย่าง
ด้วยการผสมผสาน programming model ต่างๆ
บนชุด heterogeneous resource
ตัวอย่างเช่น เราแทน algorithm ของเราได้
เป็น task workflow โดยมี task
สำหรับการเตรียม quantum circuit ที่ทับซ้อน
กับ target state ตามด้วย task
สำหรับ transpilation ซึ่งใช้แค่ทรัพยากรคลาสสิก
ถัดไปจะเป็น task
ที่ใช้ primitive เพื่อ execute quantum circuit ของเรา
ซึ่งแน่นอนต้องใช้ทรัพยากรควอนตัม
และจากนั้นจะมี task post-processing ซึ่งอาจ
เป็น diagonalization algorithm แบบ parallel
ที่รันบนหลาย node
นอกจากนี้เราอาจต้องการรัน
algorithm เหล่านั้นหลายครั้ง
ในขณะที่เราเปลี่ยน ansatz
หรือรันพร้อมกันทั้งหมดแบบ parallel
ด้วย parameter ที่ต่างกัน
ทีนี้มารวมทุกอย่างเข้าด้วยกันกับ SKQD
ใน code กัน นี่คือ task file ทั้งหมดของเรา
และนี่คือ submission file ทั้งหมด
ใน mapping task เราเตรียม circuit
ใน optimization step เรารัน circuit ด้วยวิธีที่ดีที่สุด
ใน execution task เราสุ่มตัวอย่าง bitstring
จาก state ที่ถูกเตรียมโดย
ISA circuit ของเรา
ที่ได้จาก step ก่อนหน้า
และเราก็ทำ post-processing
ตอนนี้เราพร้อมแล้วที่จะ submit
workflow ของเรา
อย่างที่เห็น ทุกอย่างรันตามลำดับ
ตาม dependency รอผล
และเราตรวจสอบ output file ได้
นี่คือ output file ของ optimization step
ที่มี ISA circuit ของเรา
และสุดท้ายมาดู end-of-job
duration กัน
จาก schedule
เท่านี้ก็เป็นอันจบการ demo สั้นๆ ของ SKQD workflow
code ทั้งหมดจะอยู่ในส่วน text
หรือในคำอธิบายด้านล่าง
เท่านี้แหละ เราได้พูดถึง
แนวคิดและตัวอย่างบางส่วนที่ช่วยให้เริ่มต้นกับ
การจัดการ hybrid program ที่ซับซ้อน แน่นอนว่า
ถ้าสนใจ นี่ยังเป็นแค่ผิวเผินของ
ทุกสิ่งที่ทำได้ด้วยการผสมผสานระหว่างควอนตัม
และทรัพยากรคลาสสิก เพื่อสำรวจเพิ่มเติม
ลองดู documentation และ tutorial
บน IBM Quantum Platform
และอย่าลืมดู resource ที่แชร์ไว้ในส่วน text
หรือคำอธิบายสำหรับข้อมูลเพิ่มเติม
และซอฟต์แวร์ต่างๆ ขอบคุณที่รับชม
เยี่ยมเลย